everybody thank you so much for joining
us today welcome to the r Studio
Enterprise Community Meetup I'm Rachel
I'm actually calling in from Connecticut
today we are streaming out to LinkedIn
and YouTube live right now well
hopefully we're streaming out to both
right now but if you've just joined now
feel free to say hi through the chat
window and maybe where you're calling in
from today we are joined by my friend
Adam Austin at so cure who is going to
be sharing how they monitor models and
alert at scale with rstudio connect if
this is your first time joining one of
these Meetup sessions welcome this is a
friendly and open Meetup environment for
teams to share use cases teach lessons
learned and just meet each other and ask
questions
together we are all dedicated to making
this an inclusive and open environment
for everyone no matter your experience
industry or background
I'll share a link in the chat in just a
moment here where you can find out about
other upcoming events too
during the event you are able to ask
anonymous questions as well
in addition to writing in on LinkedIn or
YouTube wherever you're watching from
and we'll share that link to the slido
in a second here too
we'll try to answer as many questions as
possible after the presentation too
but with all that said thank you so much
for joining us here today and thank you
so much Adam for sharing your experience
with us I'll pull Adam here in a second
up here in a second Adam is a senior
data scientist and was previously in our
studio administrator at so cure a
leading provider of identity identity
verification and fraud prevention
services
his work focuses on data science
enablement through tools Automation and
Reporting
thank you so much Adam I'll pull you up
here on stage with me
how are you doing today doing well how
are you great thank you for joining us
I'm going to head backstage and turn it
over to you
all right thank you so much and welcome
everybody thanks so much for joining
today
um like Rachel said our topic today is
model monitors and alerting at scale
with our studio connect
and uh just wanted to give a shout out I
believe in the audience
um our
um Gordon Shotwell who is a colleague of
mine at so cure and
Jonathan Keane who is a former so curian
as we call them and they were both
instrumental in
sort of developing the foundation of
this whole monitoring and alerting
framework so shout out to them I'm sure
they'll keep me honest in the chat
throughout the call uh because they were
kind of there in the beginning and I'm
and I'm all I'm just a I'm about a
messenger in this whole this whole
voyage
oh I lost your audio for just a second
here
you're right sorry that was my there you
go okay okay cool thank you
yeah so so
um a bit about me I've been doing data
science for about eight years I've been
at so here for about a year and a half
I'm uh sort of Chicago adjacent so uh
I'm I'm out there in the Chicago suburbs
and um
if if you want to follow me on Twitter
or like go find my GitHub you're welcome
to do that I don't have a lot of time to
uh tweet or to to develop unfortunately
uh because I have a whole lot of side
projects so this is it right here this
is my fam and um yeah anyway that's
that's a little bit about me so
um I do want to talk about so cure
briefly just to give you a little bit of
context for where I'm coming from and if
you did see um Gordon's talk Gordon
Shotwell my colleague he spoke at the
Meetup a few months ago I believe about
um security and he gave a little bit of
a background about soak here but in case
you weren't there so here is uh it's a
company that that provides identity
verification and fraud prediction models
and so we're essentially a business to
business provider of model scores and
insights via our API so we're not
consumer facing so if you haven't heard
of us that's just because we don't
really sell to the the general public we
sell to businesses
and the idea there is there's a number
of firms like Banks is a good example
have regulatory requirements around uh
who they can do business with and
um around a certain minimum standard of
authentication verification of their
users and so we provide services around
that to them
also things like financial institutions
um and any any firm that has an interest
in in moving money around Financial
transactions or essentially working with
your private personal data might also
want to
prevents fraud because it's just good
for business so they want to keep losses
low so those are our clients and to that
end we deploy multiple kinds of models
and we serve model scores to our clients
through our apis and our clients come
from all kinds of Industries so when I
say we deploy a model what I mean is we
develop a predictive model based on all
kinds of attributes about a person and
those models basically say are you who
you say you are
and do you have good intentions so
that's kind of from what our business is
and so we will put a model in production
which means it's behind an API that a
business can then make a call to and say
Here's somebody applying for an account
at our institution can you tell us is
this person legit and do they have good
intentions
so put that out of the way why are we
here today
so we deploy models like I said but that
really isn't the end of the story the
performance of that model matters
obviously uh it matters over time it's
gonna matter it's going to matter at the
model level and it's also going to
matter at the customer level so we want
to make sure that our models over time
are producing reliable stable scores
um and we also want to make sure that
each individual customer is receiving
the kinds of scores that they expect and
that they can make use of
so what we'll cover today well the name
of this talk is model monitoring and
alerting at scale with our studio
connect so I thought we would cover
first of all model monitoring and
alerting
um how we scale that up and
how we do that specifically in the arc
Studio connect framework so I think if
this is the what we do who when and why
you might want to scale it for and then
where it's all done
all right so first of all model
monitoring and alerting what what does
that even mean
so what is a monitor
um and it's simplest terms to me a
monitor is a visual presentation of
model metrics
that is refreshed regularly
and will notify you if something is
wrong this is sort of the three
components I think of when I think of
monitoring so basically making sure that
everything is running smoothly and it's
a place you can go to visually see
what's happening it's something that
should be constantly updating so it's
always kept current so you're never
caught off guard by anything that goes
wrong and it should alert you if things
do go wrong so I use that word alert
what actually is an alert so this is
going to be some kind of notification of
abnormal data inputs or perhaps model
outputs
and you want to be alerted if something
goes wrong so that you can respond
quickly maybe you need to retrain your
models or maybe you need to look into a
problem with an upstream data source or
maybe you just need to communicate with
a customer or in our case and for some
curious case we want to communicate with
the customer and say hey we notice that
our scores are changing is something
different on your end or should we do
some more digging on our end
so an example of an alert might be you
know suddenly you're getting too few
records from an input data source
um maybe you have just sudden spike in
bad input data so too many missing
values maybe you're getting the wrong
Factor levels coming through and your
model can't score those
maybe you have certain input values that
are exceeding expected thresholds so
they're too high they're too low and
that just looks weird to you
and also very importantly you want to
make sure that your models are producing
the right kinds of scores so when you're
building a model and vetting it you're
going to produce a sort of certain
expected distribution of model scores
and you want to make sure that those
things don't change over time through
um you know drift in the kinds of
Records you're scoring and that sort of
thing so if if your model scores change
considerably that might have impacts
um in so curious case for our clients in
terms of how they're thinking about
their customers so you want to make sure
that we alert them to that
foreign
so how are we actually going to do this
monitoring and learning well this is a
great job for our markdown or uh
of course quarto is sort of the the new
our markdown if you will it's a uh it's
it's a bit of a replacement for for our
markdown um but when we were developing
this system we've been using our
markdown and it works really well for us
so why would we use our markdown in this
case well it has obviously infinite
flexibility
um you can compute any function of your
data
and this is important because there are
a lot of really great Monitoring
Solutions out there different kinds of
companies provide ways for you to
monitor your data and your models
um a lot a lot of those Solutions
are are a little bit Limited in how you
actually compute functions of your data
so maybe you maybe you're forced into
using certain kinds of of SQL queries or
maybe you're forced into using a kind of
certain proprietary language to compute
and construct your statistics and that
can be a little bit limiting with our
markdown you're just using r or even
python if you want and so you can
compute any function of your data
our markdown is great for hosting
because you can publish and refresh your
reports on rstudio connect
and we'll see more about that in just a
minute
and our markdown is really nice because
R has a huge Suite of Integrations you
can choose to send out alerts via email
you can use slack you can use Gchat you
can use it Microsoft teams and so on and
so forth there's all kinds of great
Integrations where you can choose
different channels to send your alerts
to based on your needs
I think email is nice because even
though it requires more setup to get
going I think there's a bit more
flexibility in what you can report to
end users there and it also allows
um your users who are receiving these
alerts to use Advanced filtering and
things like that to um to meet their own
needs
okay so just to kind of level Set uh
what is what's an example of a monitor
again it's just it's just our markdown
here at uh at secure we have a nice
custom template that we apply to our our
markdown so that when it renders it has
this cool theming
and again it's just it's just going to
be a report and it's going to visually
present to you some information so maybe
you're interested in again the number of
input records you have over time
um the percent of missing values you get
over time so on and so forth so you can
you can
go to this report you can examine all
these things over time and then also
once this is deployed to connect
this can refresh and send you an alert
if there is a problem so you don't have
to be constantly watching this thing all
the time because as you scale up and you
have more and more monitors that just
becomes too time consuming too
burdensome
foreign
so let's discuss what the anatomy of
this thing really is so this is sort of
the nice polished finished product
but what's actually the guts of this
thing what's going on how does this
thing come together
I think that this is having three parts
uh there's going to be a header section
there's going to be sort of a the bulk
of the monitor which is around making
sure you can get your data you transform
that data and then you can visualize it
create plots and things like that tables
and then there's a final component which
is taking
that output data and deciding whether or
not you're going to alert
so we'll walk through each of these
sections and see what these look like
so first of all the header if you've
written in our markdown file before
you've certainly seen this yaml header
before so that's where you specify your
title your author the kind of output
you're going to create so if it's HTML
PDF Etc
but I do want to call out one particular
thing that you can add here and this is
and this is especially for our studio
connect if you're going to be alerting
from connect
you want to
think about when those alerts are going
to fire
so when you deploy a report to connect
you can choose to set that report to
refresh on a regular basis
and when it refreshes it's going to want
to send
to send an email what you can do is you
can actually suppress that email until
you absolutely need to
to send it and that's going to be when
you have an alert so there's this little
Block in the yaml header you can add the
rmd output metadata section where you
can say I want to generally suppress
and our studio connect email and then
I'll turn this off later on if I have to
fire an alert
I'll show you that in a second
okay in the middle part of this monitor
this is just where you're going to have
all of your logic all of your R code
maybe your python code to pull your data
compute your statistics
plot things create tables Etc this is
all just what you would expect from a
standard R markdown file
now the alerting part is kind of where
some of the some of the magic happens so
um I said again it's just it's it's just
part of the standard markdown workflow
this is just another R code chunk in
this case uh but we're going to be
relying on two packages in particular
one is obviously the r markdown package
and one is the blastula package and
blast Shield is this is this really cool
uh
um package to help you uh email out
reports it makes it super easy to do
especially in the rstudio connect
environment so
this is just kind of a high level
overview here I'm I'm taking my
previously created statistics and
functions of my data and I'm going to
process some alerts and at this point
I'm going to say do I have any alerts
that is do I have anything that I see
concerning in my data do I have too many
missing values do I have model scores
that are too high or too low whatever it
is and then you can decide in this code
chunk whether or not you want to fire an
alert so if you do have any alerts at
that point
you're going to use the r markdown
package
to then
say I'm no longer going to be
suppressing my emails
I'm going to tell connect I'm ready to
send an email now
and then next I'm going to use the the
blastula package to render my connect
email and I'm going to use this alert
email template which I'll show you in a
second
and I'm going to attach
this email and I'm going to send it off
to my recipients
so this does require a configuration on
the our studio connect server so if this
is something that you want to do you can
talk to your rstudio administrator and
they can help you get set up with these
emails
foreign
so I mentioned this alert email template
and let me just show you what I mean by
that so you have here you have a monitor
markdown file
and then what you're doing is you're
calling a secondary
markdown in this case it's just going to
be an alert email template and I call
this the alerting buddy system so if
you've deployed this monitor to connect
you're also going to want to deploy this
this little helper
markdown and this is just going to be
this is going to consist of a header and
a body and the header now is going to
contain this blastula function which
specifically renders this as a blastula
email
and then in the body of of this alert
markdown it's just going to be any
content that you want to report if you
want to put a table in there if you want
to just put some custom text that just
says hey there's an alert go check your
monitor you can do that if you want to
put a table a plot whatever it is
you can put that all in here
so one thing to
to
um to be aware of here is that this this
alert email markdown file when it's
called
in your code it's being rendered
within the scope
of your original monitor so you don't
need to recompute anything here you
don't need to pull new data all of all
of the objects that are available in
this environment here in your monitor
are going to be available in your alert
email
as well so
that's just one thing to keep in mind
so what does that actually look like
when it's when it fires an alert in this
case
uh we have green gets bank and you know
they the maybe they had some some model
score drifts and maybe they had some
input uh some input variables that have
exceeded their thresholds and so in this
case uh this this alert goes out and
comes into my inbox overnight because
that's when the report ran and
this just gives me a little bit of
information so so this text was rendered
in my alert email our markdown
and then what's nice about this is this
comes into my inbox uh I get in first
thing in the morning I see there was an
alert and now I can go click down here
and I can just go right to the report
and see those plots and make sure that
everything is looking good and if it's
not I can go investigate
okay so that's
what a monitor is
sort of how the email system works here
why would we want to monitor from our
studio connect in general
uh well it's unreasonably easy to deploy
reports there it's super nice to be able
to tag and categorize your content and
so what those tags do is it allows you
to search and filter and find find your
monitors
find any report reports or content that
you've deployed you can also really
easily schedule your refreshes there so
you can schedule a report to run
overnight you can schedule it to run
every hour if you want more frequent
updates
and there are tools for scaling and that
is the Crux of what I want to get into
next but first I'll stop and um let's
just see if we have any questions that
came in from that first section
Rachel anything you want to call out
let's see I I saw one question over on
LinkedIn but I first wanted to remind
people that you can ask questions
wherever you're watching from so
LinkedIn or YouTube but you can also ask
questions anonymously at this slido link
too
um but one of the questions that came in
was from Gary and it was
does this tie into site reliability
engineering principles and practices
that's a great question uh I mean
insofar as you need to Monitor and
evaluate processes that are happening
so I mean so this I I guess what I
called out here is specifically around
um
so I called out here uh specifically
like
a data process so do I have
too few records from a data source bad
input data Etc you can you can
theoretically use this to monitor
anything you want right so anything
that's going on in your organization as
long as you have the data
um yeah you can you can absolutely use
this as as a monitor for those processes
I think the challenge there is making
sure that you have access to the right
data sources and
um are able to hook that up to your
connect system but otherwise yeah
absolutely you can um you can keep tabs
on anything you need in terms of you
know who's accessing what systems and
um you know the uptime of your systems
as long as you can get that data
awesome thank you I see one other
question that came through on on slido
that we'll cover now too and it was how
much tweaking is required to make sure
you alert when necessary and don't when
not do you have a standard process for
that tweaking
yeah absolutely that's a that's a really
great question and we're going to
address that in the next section yeah so
um because you can think about as you
begin to scale up and deploy a lot of
monitors
um you might run into the situation
where you're alerting a lot and
you know maybe you've set your
thresholds to the wrong levels and um
you absolutely want to keep that in mind
as you begin to grow the number of
monitors that you're deploying and we'll
touch on that in the next section
perfect thank you cool
right so
all right next section at scale
um so it's one thing to build a model
Monitor and make it fire alerts um you
know it takes a little bit of setting up
but once you've got it going it's super
nice then how do you scale this up and
so I want to talk a little bit about our
journey at secure
and thinking about when do you need to
start scaling and uh my my middle two
boys are just like super into Power
Rangers right now so this just came to
mind I'm not thinking about scaling
um so you want to start scheduling when
you have a sudden growth in the number
of models that you're deploying or maybe
clients who are receiving
um your reports maybe you have a large
customer base either inside your own
company or outside your your company
and you just need to be able to keep
tabs on a lot of different things at
once and again you can't spend all day
just staring at monitors
so you want to make sure you have a
system by which if you have a lot of
things going on you can only get those
alerts that really matter
you also might consider scaling up when
you're overwhelmed by making updates you
know to to that question that we just
had uh you know if you have
tuning if you if you think about how do
you tune those thresholds and and how do
you alert only when you have to
um maybe you want to make that more of a
self-service process for the users of
your monitors and that would be a a good
opportunity to think about how to scale
so I'm going to walk you through
how this process happened at secure and
maybe your business doesn't look quite
like this but hopefully uh you can at
least learn from
from from our process and and find
places where the same ideas and
principles can apply to you or at least
maybe learn from um you know just some
of the growing pains that we had as we
were going through this as well so some
of the background here is that um is
that so cure grew very quickly
um in the past couple years and our
Revenue doubled
um
year over year for a few years in a row
and so you're growing our customer base
uh significantly and that became kind of
challenging going from just a few
monitors to all of a sudden we need this
whole ecosystem so I'll just kind of
walk you through that process and while
I'm doing that uh again I'm sure I'm
sure Gordon and Jonathan can keep me
honest because they were they were there
in the beginning but when all this was
started so um hopefully they can call
call out uh some added info as necessary
but um
let's first look at how monitoring helps
secure succeed
and to do this I want to just kind of
simplify our business model a little bit
just for the sake of illustration so you
know in simple terms at secure we have a
data science team
we have some account managers and
they're responsible for understanding
client needs communicating some of that
back to our data scientists and sort of
being uh you know being these Liaisons
and Reps for so cure
and then um
what happens is like I mentioned before
our clients will call our API and they
will get model scores back as a result
and then all of that data lands in our
databases so that we have visibility
into what's actually happening with our
products
and from there once that data is in our
databases our data scientists can
publish a monitor or a report that
ingests that data and displays you know
some of the stats some of the health of
our business
so in in Broad terms that's kind of how
we think about it and that's the
framework we're going to use for
thinking about scaling going forward
here
so once those monitors are deployed our
account managers can view these reports
these monitors might fire alerts back to
our account managers and then based on
that information our account managers
can decide whether and how to
communicate back to our clients what's
happening with our products
Okay so
let's think about
the scaling process and sort of the
level one
um the the first step you might take in
in monitoring a client or monitoring a
model is just to create something
bespoke or just to create a custom
monitor uh for every individual client
or or every individual need when you
when you're small it kind of makes sense
to start out that way
um because you know maybe you only have
a few customers or a few models and
you're kind of learning which metrics
are useful and what's the right refresh
Cadence and how do we send alerts and so
forth so perhaps it looks like this
where you get a new clients and the
account manager comes and says we need
to monitor cocoa inputs and the bad egg
model scores for this new client Wonka
Willy Wonka so he's he's our customer
now so data science says okay cool we
can do that
we're going to build a custom monitor
we're going to publish that to connect
and now our account managers can view
that and can receive alerts
okay time goes on and now we acquire
some new customers
and now we have green guts bank and now
we also have Dunder Mifflin these are
our new clients so
our account managers say okay we're
gonna you know look at some specific
model outputs for these clients and so
data science goes and publishes custom
reports for those clients as well
so again we're this is still sort of the
prototyping phase
figuring out you know which metrics are
actually useful
and this is a good place to start
the trouble here is that this can be
very time consuming maybe every monitor
looks different so you know it's a
little bit it's a little bit hard to go
from one monitor monitor to the other
and understand sort of what's happening
in each one it's a little bit of like
cognitive overhead there so
as time goes on you will want to
begin to standardize via a template
sorry this should be level two so in
level two you're going to be thinking
about
um can we monitor some key inputs and
model scores across all the clients so
maybe there are some clients that
require a little bit of extra
customization and that's totally fine
but can we figure out maybe a templated
solution where for most of our clients
we just know these are the
these are the inputs we care about and
these are the outputs we care about
so customization kind of becomes
secondary and you just want that
consistency
those standardized reporting practices
so what might that look like data
science might decide to create a report
template
and and this is this is how we did it
for a while as well
um and this template is going to contain
a lot of
logic in the body of that report and all
that logic is going to be essentially
the same for each client but
um what you'll do is is you can go in in
each report and say uh you know
this this report is for uh
for Willy Wonka or this report is for
green guts or whoever it is and then the
downstream logic can then go and grab
the data specific to those clients and
then each report can be
a
templated version of of this standard
monitoring framework except it's client
specific
so in our case that's secure what we did
is we created a template and then we
we customized each template and deployed
into a gitlab repo
and so now we have a whole bunch of
monitors each one
showing the same kinds of things but
each one for a different client and then
we can use what's called this get backed
deployment process in our studio connect
to actually pull those reports straight
into connect which is super nice because
if you wanted to go in later and update
one of these templates maybe you wanted
to
tweak a threshold value for one of your
alerts you could do that you could push
those changes to gitlab and then maybe
the next day our studio connect is going
to go grab those changes and then
publish those reports on connect
so this was really helpful
um this is this is a really nice system
for a while the problem here is that
this is a little bit time consuming and
there's a multi-step deployment process
that can be a little bit cumbersome
again as you continue to scale up
which is what happened to us
so time goes by and all of a sudden we
have a lot more clients and our account
managers are asking for a lot more
monitors and so
um we have to begin again thinking about
uh how do we reduce a little bit of the
friction on the data science team and
and how do we make this again even still
more automated
and to that end we came up with a
package and this package was all about
deploying a report by by combining or
marrying this this template
and now a a client specific config or a
configuration
and those two things together create a
monitor
so broadly speaking in this Auto monitor
package and I'll talk more about the
specifics later but partly speaking
there's this deploy function and deploy
just says give me your account name
and give me your configuration and I
will put together a template and the
configuration and I will create a
monitor and I will deploy that
so this template can live inside your
package so you just throw it in the uh
in the ins directory
and then this configuration is just
going to be a list of client specific
details monitoring thresholds and so
forth
also inside that this Auto monitor
package are just your standard
monitoring functions and so those are
what get used inside your template
and you can use this and this is like
super cool you can use the RS connect
package and the connect API
package to add viewer permissions you
can set your refresh schedule you can
tag deployed content so it's easy to
find you can do all these really cool
things programmatically so you don't
have to deploy a report and then go to
connect and configure everything
manually you can do all this
programmatically from our
so now with Auto monitor we can just say
I want to deploy I'm going to deploy for
you know this specific client maybe you
have a set of of config defaults so you
don't have to worry about that either
you can just programmatically run
through all these client names and then
push out all these reports from your
console
so now you're cooking with gas
Everything feels good
except the problem here becomes
you have all these reports now and
unless you take the time to go in and
and customize all of the configs and all
of the alerting thresholds and this gets
back to our earlier question what's
going to happen you have this these
default set of thresholds
and because they're not uh client
specific and customized for the client
needs you're just going to get tons of
alerts right so
um we you know you kind of want to set
these overly cautious alerting
thresholds so you're not missing
anything but because each client has
different needs based on their business
you're probably just going to end up
with a mess of alerts and this becomes
overwhelming you get a lot of false
positives you get a lot of alert fatigue
which just means people are just going
to stop reading their alerts because
they're just tired of staring at them
um and and what ends up happening is
you're going to require a lot of updates
to these monitors by hand
by your data scientists so you end up
kind of in this
in this jira Inferno right where account
managers need updates to their monitors
and so they're submitting all these
tickets and they're saying please update
these thresholds so we're not getting
all these alerts because we're alerting
too frequently and this threshold is is
not relevant to my client
and that becomes overwhelming and data
science makes the rage face
so
time goes by and
um what we came up with is a
self-service monitoring ecosystem
and data science says download your
tickets long-lived self-service and now
here's the old world where account
managers are getting all these alerts
they could submit tickets
or
in our case what we chose to do is
deploy a shiny app
so now this is a web app that that faces
our account managers and their account
managers can go in and
in that shiny app
choose their clients
and then change the configurations on
those
configs so they're changing the
thresholds at which alerts are fired in
and that app will then go and update
those monitors so that you're actually
getting
fewer alerts and and what you're getting
is not just fewer alerts you're getting
the right alerts so you're getting the
alerts only when they matter
this is a little bit hand wavy and
there's actually a lot more going on
behind the scenes and I'll take a look
at that in just a minute
but first I want to give you a little
bit of a live demo of what that shiny
app looks like
so
let me run this app
make sure this so
this is actually uh this is actually an
example of what our account managers see
and
um
well it's it's basically a list of all
of our clients it gives the account ID
and and then it tells you what was the
last alert date so that
the reason we're showing this here and
we and we actually sort by the state is
you know if if you wake up in the
morning and you get all these alerts and
you're just sick and tired of it you can
go to this app and you can find the
accounts that are alerting right away so
let's um let's update
update grain gets I'll click on grain
gets here
and what pops up is a panel where I can
configure
my like I can configure my config file
so what I'll do is I'll open this this
general settings tab and now you can see
that
um
this is all of the parameters and things
that go into our alerting framework so
let's say we just deployed a new model
um for gringits so I want to go here to
my model names and I want to add this
new industry specific model for gringits
and I want to get rid of this uh old
fraud model okay give me that
and now
[Music]
um
I noticed that my monitor is only
showing me the past 90 days of History
I'm actually interested in 180 days of
history for that client
and with that I will say okay I'm ready
to go I'm going to hit update
okay so I've updated the config for that
client so the next time that report
refreshes
it's going to use those settings so they
can go back to green gets and I can see
indeed I have my industry specific model
here and I have my 180 days of History
all right so again this is still high
level kind of hand wavy I'm going to
show you in a bit exactly how that gets
executed behind the scenes
foreign
but that's the end of this section so
that's that's the idea of how we scale
that's so cure and let's pause for
questions if we have any
yes we do have a few questions and I
also wanted to bring Tatsu on because he
was going to be my co-host and I
completely forgot to send him the link
so what's up man welcome Tatsu yeah
thank you for joining us if you want to
also introduce yourself to everyone
I'm
go ahead I was just gonna say so Tatsu
works with many of our Consulting and
high-tech companies like so care so just
wanted to bring you in to to meet
everyone too
yeah absolutely no I've been I've been
working
um for our studio uh and with Adam's
team for probably around the same time
that Adam said at Soak here so I've kind
of seen Adam from uh his Inception
um of the team and and and to even come
this far and it's really cool to see
this uh I wasn't that baby
I was there before your your most recent
baby that's right that's right that's
right yeah that's it
and I see you both have your R studio uh
swag on I definitely should have been
wearing in our studio shirt here
um limited edition of nowadays right so
there are a few other questions on slido
and one was about
python support So Cordo and our markdown
products have great python support what
else if anything is needed to have this
similar workflow in Python yeah
um
uh
I mean I think what's nice about this
ecosystem is uh with quarto and our
markdown you can I mean you can blend
the languages if you want to so you can
have python uh code chunks where you
need to
um and you can have
um you can have the r code charts where
you need to so
um I I don't actually know so you know I
I showed up before like in the yaml
header of the the monitor file where you
have to have that um
that's special like our markdown or I'm
sorry that our theater connect email
suppression I I don't know if quarto
supports that right now somebody can
correct me if I'm if I'm wrong
um I I know quarto is is is different
from our markdown in a lot of ways and I
don't know but if it has that
functionality
um but otherwise Tom mock or Isabella
Velasquez to magically appear yeah
exactly exactly if we say their name
three times will they will they appear
um
yeah but but I mean otherwise
you know again you can just use Python
to create to create your alert logic to
pull in data
um to make plots all those things are
supported in in both quarto and our
markdown so you can really do
you know all the same stuff and and now
there's there's shiny for python as well
so if you even wanted to build that
shiny app in Python and deploy it you
can totally do that
um it's it's it's a great time to be in
our studio user in in that regard
um I did meet a call out earlier too I
mean you said um Isabel so so Julia
silgi and Isabelle is it um Velasquez uh
Zimmerman I'm sorry Zimmerman um
um they they gave a talk
um it's a a couple of weeks ago on on
vetiver which is this nice like ml Ops
sort of ecosystem that's that you can
use in both R and python
um and especially in conjunction with
connect and there are um
there are a lot of
great ways to model your monitors with
vetiver as well both in our and python
absolutely yeah and I'll share that link
to that Meetup recording um in the chat
in just a second here too
yeah I'm gonna read this uh next
question here
um for you Adam can this be integrated
with data dog or other similar
monitoring tools uh an org might already
have in place
yeah
um
you know that's that's a great question
it's something that it's it's one that I
should know the answer to and um
maybe Gordon can come to my rescue I'm
sure he knows the answer
um it's it's you know it's it like in so
far as
um
so so insofar as something like datadog
can
um
let's come back this actually because
um what I want to call out next is is
some of the architecture behind this
whole setup and maybe that will answer
some of your questions
um but you know like from the connect
side as long as you know if you have
data flowing into datadog maybe you want
to then pull pull that into connect I
don't actually know if you can do that
I'm I'm sure there's a way but I don't
actually have enough familiarity with
the datadog or the other monitoring
tools because um I've got my head so so
deep in this in this world here so
let's take one more question
we'll go to the to the next section too
um but one was how would an account
manager know what values to use while
updating the configuration do you
provide simulated or historical examples
to help guide those
yeah it's it's a really good it's a
really good point um I think you know I
think there's a lot of things you could
do because our markdown is so flexible
you you could
sort of analyze client history and
provide suggestions or even just like
instead of instead of just having a
naive default set of thresholds and
things when you when you deploy the
deployment process itself could maybe
pull in some data and do some kind of
historical analysis and say these are
the thresholds I think kind of make
sense
um the account manager kind of has to
you know read the reports make sure they
understand the client history and then
you know it's it's up to them as well to
understand the client's use cases and
what they're going to do with all those
model scores to then understand okay at
what point do we need to begin alerting
for this client so it really it really
can be I mean there's a there's a
limited set of things you can do
automatically
um maybe even in like a model based way
to set those thresholds but
I think at the end of the day you want a
human being working with the client to
kind of like make those judgment calls
cool thank you before Tatsu and I
disappear backstage just wanted to
remind everyone that if you do want to
ask other questions if you joined a bit
later we also have a slido link where
you can ask those anonymously or you can
just post them into YouTube or LinkedIn
too cool thank you great
okay
um we've been talking about connect this
whole time but I want to dig a little
bit more into uh how connect is playing
a role here because it's sort of the
glue that holds everything together and
we're going to get more in the Weeds
about what exactly is happening behind
the scenes so
let's talk kind of about the
architecture again we'll keep this high
level
um but just so you know actually what
happens when we think about updating a
monitor
um this is the picture we saw before so
account managers are looking at monitors
they're looking at this web app
um
an account manager goes to configure
the monitor from this web app and so now
what's actually happening well behind
the scenes the web app is actually
interacting at least in so curious case
is interacting with a plumber API
so a plumber API if if you're not
familiar with apis they're just a system
for uh computers or programs to talk to
one another so to communicate to send
data back and forth so what actually
happens here is shiny
um what when you hit that update button
in that shiny app what it does is it
will send a request to this API
to say hey I need you to update this one
particular config file and the API will
say okay I'm going to do that and the
API goes and it updates
a set of config files that are living in
the connect storage so connect just has
you know it's it's sitting on a server
and the server has storage and so we
have a bunch of config files sitting on
connect and the API will just go and
make those changes to the config file
that you requested or sorry to the
client that you requested it for
okay from there the config files the
next time the monitor is refresh the
monitors then pull in that information
from the config files and that's
actually where they're getting their
thresholds from so we've uh sort of
um we've sort of separated the monitors
from that configuration and those
settings all of those thresholds and
things and so that makes it really easy
now to make changes to how those
monitors are actually
um are actually alerting
so what actually is this config file you
know I said there's files sitting on the
server and that's further in this case
that they're just Json files so whereas
previously I said you know a
configuration could be like a list of
thresholds now in this case uh it's
essentially just like a language
agnostic form of that same thing so in
this case it's just jsons so if we're
looking at the Willy Wonka company uh
you know we might have the wonka.json
file sitting here on connect and this
just has things like the account name
the account ID the model names they're
interested in what's your reporting
window and then all of your thresholds
so make that as long as you want
um
and basically the deeper you get into
data science the more you realize it's
all just Json and yaml and that's it's
pretty much what everything converges to
so
um
so then when a when a monitor
goes and refreshes what it's actually
doing inside that monitor is we have uh
these functions from the auto monitor
package
and the they're basically a suite of API
interaction functions that just go out
and talk to the plumber API
and then make a request for that config
so when this monitor refreshes it's just
going to say hey I need the latest
version of of my config file and the API
says great here it is and from there we
can now use that data Downstream in our
monitors so
uh in our case and so here we refresh
these monitors every night and so every
night each monitor goes out and grabs
its specific set of thresholds and
brings those in so if a if an account
manager had made a change
during that day that will be reflected
the next day in the report
okay so you might be saying that sounds
really convoluted and it kind of is
um although I will say plumber apis they
if you're not familiar with apis they
sound kind of scary and kind of magical
um
actually the plumber package makes it so
easy to deploy an API that we should all
be doing it just for fun so
um
but the the broader question is why
would we use an API in the first place
um
and
the basic idea is that it's it it really
makes it simple to add configs to our
connect storage during deployment so you
think about this deployment process
again it's a template plus a config file
and you get a monitor
okay so I'll use Auto monitor to deploy
a monitor and that sends a monitor to
connect that's great
um but my config file actually gets
pushed through our plumber API and then
ends up on the server
um and then why is you know why is that
important why we do it that way well
it's it's actually it's actually the
easiest way to get uh to get something
right onto your your connect server
um so now I can just be sitting here I'm
a data scientist I can be totally
abstracted away from from where this
stuff lives and you know how it gets
updated all you know I just I just have
this nice API sitting there that I can
then use and then also in our Auto our
Auto monitor package we include API
interaction functions that allow you to
create configs retrieve configs update
configs delete configs and so forth so
all of our data scientists have a nice
set of tools at their disposal if they
wanted to interact with these configs
sitting on connect
and this also makes it really nice just
for programmatic deployments or updates
so
um in addition any other sort of local
development or app testing or access by
other applications company-wide is made
super easy by having this API there so
you know say we wanted to migrate the
monitor system somewhere else and we had
that question about datadog
um you know maybe there are other
systems that we want to switch to or
even use in addition to these monitors
the question is well how would we
communicate with those other systems
what are thresholds that we're currently
using are and the answer is just stick
an API and connect and now all all these
systems company-wide can talk to that
API so you know if we had some other
monitoring system
um instead of connect if we just decided
to migrate all of our monitoring
somewhere else well we still have these
configuration files that are useful
um account managers still want to
configure those things themselves so now
we can move to a separate monitoring
system while still retaining this nice
API but then stores our configs
all right
um
apis are also really cool on connect
because they come with
Swagger docs for free so when you deploy
an API you get a nice set of
documentation that comes with that and
uh let's just take a look at that
because if you've never deployed an API
maybe this sounds like gibberish
um but this is essentially what the
documentation looks like when you deploy
an API so API has these things called
endpoints which are just like URLs that
you can go and send information to and
get information from
um and so this is a this is a swaggered
documentation that the plumber will
build for you which is so nice when you
create an API and so now you can if you
know something has a question about oh
how does this API work how do I interact
with it or some engineer somewhere else
in the company wants to interact with it
that you just point them here and you
have this nice set of documentation you
can
um you know in in this case if I wanted
to get a client's configuration file I
can use this specific endpoint here and
you can open it up and they tell you you
know what kinds of information the
endpoint is expecting and then you can
um
you can practice here if you wanted to
um but by adding information to this
this argument and executing so it's
super nice
um it it it it helps people understand
exactly what's happening behind the
scenes if they need to
all right
um
I've been talking a lot so I'm gonna I'm
gonna start wrapping it up here but uh
you know one
this is uh yeah so so this is kind of
our current state wherever I left you
here this is our current state here
um of monitoring there's a future State
you could imagine where you don't
necessarily have to involve data science
in every single deployment so I showed
before how data science uses the auto
monitor package to deploy things
programmatically
um to deploy monitors and that works
great if you even wanted to remove them
from the equation a little bit you know
you could think about providing a deploy
feature to your shiny app so the account
managers can go in and deploy new
monitors as they as they get new
accounts
um you could even think about maybe
having a process that that grabs grabs
all of our data looks for looks for new
accounts and if it sees a new account
Auto deploy is a monitor uh sets up a
config Etc so you can think of a world
that you know is is even more hands-off
um we haven't moved there yet but that's
something that's that's also within the
Revel possibility
um okay one thing I do want to call out
with connect
um that really helped enable this
process for us is uh the usage of what
they call external packages these are
like system-wide packages so
um
the idea here is that is that we as data
scientists can build a package like in
our case Auto Monitor and then we can
create a an installation on connect and
that is the version that our API is
going to use
um or that our monitors are going to use
and that our shiny African is going to
use and so the idea there is that you
just have this one nice standardized
version that every that every System is
using and you know that it's always up
to date because you can go in and
configure that
um
and and that's just been a really nice
way to make sure that we we know exactly
what our monitors how they're going to
behave because we are controlling the
version of that package on connect
um the the documentation does say that
external packages uh decrease
reproducibility and isolation of the
content on connect and should only be
used as a last resort
um I think that's fair
we said yolo and it's actually been
working out well for us in this in this
particular instance
um
so you know there there are there are
really good use cases for these external
packages so what this means is just that
we have now a an auto monitor package
living on connect and that is going to
be the the version that shiny
our shiny app uses the version that our
monitors use and then if we ever need to
like fix a bug or anything we know that
it's fixed everywhere all at once
okay just to wrap things up
um why did we try connect for monitoring
the first place you know like we said
before there's all kinds of great
Monitoring Solutions out there
um
even if
you or your company is exploring options
for monitoring and and looking at
different vendors
the fact that if you have connect
and you're prototyping today that has a
very high value so you don't have to you
don't have to wait you know uh for for a
system to be stood up and then to go
learn that system in order to start
deploying and seeing the value of
monitors you can you know if you have
connects
have our markdown you can start doing
this stuff today and just kind of
figuring out what works
um the whole system in our case was sort
of security approved
um so we could do anything inside that
sandbox
and you know we could just play around
test out see what works
um and you know there's just there's
just no waiting around for engineering
resources or prioritization you can just
start working
um scheduling and user access control is
really effortless unconnected super nice
to just put something up and then you
know
who can see it you know how often it
gets refreshed you can change that
really easily and then also our
non-coding partners like our account
managers can be super engaged and
empowered in this whole process
um so that's why we started using
connect and now this has been
a journey that's you know longer than my
tenure at secure and um so the question
is why do we keep using connect for
monitoring even when we have other other
options at our disposal it's well it's
super cost effective for one there's no
marginal expenditure for hosting
additional monitors for building
additional apis and hosting those and
for pushing out web apps it's it's low
maintenance so
a well-designed ecosystem can run
indefinitely without intervention I
don't think I've actually touched
this system or the code in a year
because it just runs so well
um and but when we say well designed you
know that's going to include making sure
your packages are well tested and
um I I have not gotten into this in this
talk but Auto monitor is Thoroughly
tested including all of our API API
interaction calls so make sure you're
doing that but um once you do yeah it
can it can run really well
um and then just the extra control I
mean
again there's no there's no waiting
around for someone to go and configure
something for you if if you need if you
need that um you know if you're a data
scientist you can own this product and
can respond to user needs as quickly as
you'd like
foreign
so with that thank you very much
um yeah and connect has been a lifesaver
and um I tweeted out last uh last
February just like how how
connect has been uh super helpful just
in in empowering me and empowering our
end users
um to own their work so I hope that you
can uh that you can find a way to do
that too
and with that
um
have any more questions
thank you so much Adam that was awesome
really really love the examples you
shared here too I I see somebody had
asked um
on slido if you would be able to share
any of the code that you used or if
there was
like a public GitHub link that you have
um yeah unfortunately we don't have
anything public in that regard
um
yeah it's it's all going to be
proprietary to secure and things like
that so
um I can't share much yeah yeah I think
I saw you sending out links to sort of
like the um RS connect package and the
connect API and
um yeah I mean hopefully take a look at
plumber and um I you know I think with
with this framework you know I I hope
you can kind of
put those pieces together
um
but absolutely yeah
yeah and maybe our team can think about
putting together like a blog post with
some of these examples that you've
shared here too would it be possible for
um us to share the slides with the
recording I think it'd be fine yeah okay
cool I'll get those for you and just a
reminder to everybody that the recording
will be shared at the same exact YouTube
live link so will be made available
immediately after the Meetup ends too
um but thank you so much Adam I I see
there are a few other questions that
Tatsu and I will will read here
um I'll show one on the screen for you
Tatsu
it's each monitor instance correspond to
another Studio connect deployment
to an RCA connect deployment so
um I think there was some extra context
added after too
or perhaps better pose what is an auto
monitor doing under the hood when you
set up a monitor
yeah for sure let's um let me go back
okay where'd it go way back here
yeah
um yeah so I the the main way that a
data scientist would use this package is
just essentially to call this deploy
function
um so what this is doing is it says all
right here's my account name or account
ID whatever it is and deploy is going
out and and saying okay I have a
I have a template
I'm gonna go grab that template
I'm going to create a config file and
then it's
um it takes that markdown
template and it combines it with that
config file to create a
client specific monitor
and then it deploys that client-specific
monitor to our studio connect and
it also pushes that config file
through our API onto the connect storage
so
it's yeah so it's it's doing a lot of
magic with with RS connecting and and
the connect API to do things like
um
write the Manifest for this this file so
if you've ever deployed to connect
um
and you've seen that what it has to do
is is essentially write out a a manifest
which is sort of a list of all of the
packages and versions and things that
are used in there so that connect then
knows what kind of environment to build
for that piece of content and so behind
the scenes what's happening is is
um with with the help of these two
packages we're writing that manifest
um and then we're bundling all that
content up together and we're pushing
that to connect and that's made possible
Again by these things here
um and then we're adding viewer
permissions we're setting the refresh
schedule we're tagging the deployed
content again all through these nice
these nice apis here
um
so it's it's basically building it's
building that monitor it's deploying
that monitor with all these settings I
don't know if that answers your question
but essentially there's there's one
connect deployment like the there's one
RC door connect
and then each time we run this deploy
function it's creating a new piece of
content and it's pushing that content to
connect for hosting
yeah and and these tags are the way that
you essentially categorize your
information so
connect can get a little bit crazy with
all the reports and things that are in
there but once you tag something you
know that you can go and find it a tag
is just like a label and and then you
can go and and
um find all the content with that one
label so if you're looking for all your
all of your monitors you can have a like
a monitor label
yeah before we move on to the next
question I just wanted to point out that
there was some appreciation in the chat
about your your use of a YOLO YOLO
really really dating yourself there Adam
well you know I'm I'm at that age where
uh all of my memes are old so that's
true and and you know I kind of I kind
of embrace it and
um it's it's partly tongue-in-cheek but
also uh I'm just an old guy so
a really embracing dead life there you
go I went to grad school uh in Northern
California at UC Davis and it's in Yolo
County and it was just the greatest
thing
I tried to just share a link on connect
tags uh it looks like a very long weird
link there so maybe we could help find a
better one right from there okay yeah
you know
the connect API package I believe is
still under active development
um so I did share that too I shared that
into the uh into the chat too okay cool
I see there was a question a bit earlier
um from someone who doesn't have access
to connect but asked if they could use
sagemaker uh with the shiny model
monitoring and I just wanted to say that
next Tuesday we're actually going to
have
a few of the product Managers from our
team here to give a few lightning talks
and one of the people that will be
joining us is James Blair who's our
product manager for the cloud
Integrations
and so I think that would be a really
great question to ask him as well so I
wanted to share just while I'm thinking
about it
if you are curious where to find out
about future events you can look at this
calendar link here
and I'm bad at multitasking right now
but I'll share it in the chat in just
just a second too
but another question over on slido Tatsu
I'll put on the screen for you to read
what do you do when you're our markdown
template needs updating does that
handled via the app too
yeah great question so yeah what yeah
what happens if you want to add a new
kind of plot or something to your
template yeah
um
so what we did in this Auto monitor
package it's it's not just for deploying
new content but you can also
um you can also redeploy or update
existing content so if you wanted to
make a change to your template again
that template's just like a single file
that lives in your package so you could
change that that template add new
sections whatever it is and then
what's the best way to do this in in
this framework I think what I would
probably end up doing is um because
we've built in oh man
yeah we built in all these nice API
interaction functions if if I if I had
to update all those monitors what I what
I think we could do here is um go out
and grab all of the existing configs
and then that contains
um things like account name account ID
and now I can use my deploy function
which was specifically written to either
deploy new content or update existing
content and I can go say Okay
um
from this list of all of my existing
configs all my existing clients
um I I want to grab the account name and
then I want to redeploy with this new
template and that would just be done in
a loop programmatically might take a
little while but it would actually be
doable
I'm not sure I see any other questions
yet in the chat do you see any others
tattoo
um yeah do we do we do this yeah you see
Thomas asked a question
um did you look into parameterize our
markdown reports where you could
schedule and connect with new or
additional sets of parameters yeah
definitely
um
and that's something that is sort of
adjacent to
this idea here
um
where you know maybe you have a
templates and instead of writing out
separate our markdown files for each
client maybe you just have a set of
parameters in the yaml header so if you
so if you're not familiar if you
parameterize your arm markdown that just
means your yaml header is given a set of
configurable parameters which then get
passed you can pass Downstream to all of
your your R code
um so you that's definitely an option
um I think
there are some limitations with how
we're doing it here so I think one
limitation is
um
a parameterized report is like one
single monolithic piece of content on
connect and I but I don't believe that
you can
very easily control the access and the
scheduling for each individual variant
that you render so so what you can do on
connect is once you deploy that
parameterized piece of content you then
can open this nice this nice sidebar and
it it gives you a way to change all of
the input parameters to those reports
that you want to change the account ID
you want to change the reporting window
you want to change the thresholds and
then you can save what they call an uh a
variant so it's like a new version of
that report with those new parameters
and those all kind of live together in
the same piece of content with a with a
drop down menu where you can go and
select which which variant you want to
view
and I think I think there's a lot of um
Merit to that I think in this case we
just we have too many clients we have
too many monitors and it would be it's
it's a little bit like time consuming
for all of our account managers to go in
and
um you know have to go in and search for
the clients that they want to find it in
that big list of variants so it's
definitely a a good option if you have a
handful of different
um versions of the same report you want
to run I think in this case it didn't
make sense for us
can I selfishly ask a question question
right so selfishly sure I would love for
you to ask a question uh yeah absolutely
um well I I talked to a lot of uh folks
in Consulting right so it's really great
to have this example out there now Adam
again like fantastic talk
um and my question is around you know
when you came up with this right you you
had these parameters for model
monitoring that your account managers
can leverage right
um what was it kind of like before you
developed that piece and then what has
that that that change look like you said
you know it empowers the account
managers that has it created like better
um relations with your clients um what
does that look like for you yeah
um
yeah so your first question was how we
kind of hit on this right
um yeah shout out to Gordon you're still
out there I think this was sort of his
brainchild
um and and I'm sure probably Jonathan
too but um I I sort of stepped into this
into his shoes after he left secure
um yeah you know I think like it like
this this journey here that I kind of
walked us through was was our journey
and um so like this was this was the
pain right here that everyone was
feeling
um and and it was sort of the thing
we're like well
people just stopped paying attention to
their alerts because it just became too
much and you when you have too many
false positives you just assume
everything's a false positive uh and
then you miss the you missed the really
important stuff
um
and so we built this whole system
uh summer of 2021 uh more or less uh to
start thinking about you know how do we
actually
allow this this self-service
um and it it did kind of come as a
result of just all these tickets so this
is like this is like true story here it
was just it was just so many tickets
coming in and um our our poor data
scientists were just overwhelmed and it
was just too much so
um so yeah so then we
so then we kind of uh we deployed this
and honestly like I said before we
haven't really even had to do a lot of
maintenance on it um
what this what this did was it basically
reduced our tickets from
a million codes you know to to like
it's it's not just alerting noise it's
it's ticket noise and and you get
overwhelmed and you're just like okay I
spent all day like updating these files
I could be spending my time somewhere
else doing something more valuable for
the company and so this cut down uh for
us on this this long like feedback cycle
where it's like hey update this thing
let's and let's just like let's hope it
works well for me
um so and so waste data scientist time
and it waste account managers time
because in in the time it takes them to
write a ticket they could have
configured a thing anyway and then they
you know if they have to write a ticket
they have to wait for it to happen
and now they don't they just go and they
just update it and it's done
um yeah and like this is this is the
real deal like this so this like um
every now and then we'll get new account
managers coming in and they'll ask a
question and you know they'll submit a
jira ticket and I'll Point them to this
web app and and there will say that like
this is super handy and like yeah it's
just it's it's super easy for them to
use
um and yeah just it kind of removes us
from that whole
it it breaks that whole like nasty
feedback loop of
involving data science where we just
frankly we could be spending our time
doing other things so
yeah now not to mention like human error
and the shortness of our attention spans
right which can totally just
explode so yeah I love it
yeah and again like it like it feel like
this if you just look at this this feels
convoluted
um but like when you step back and you
realize oh yeah this API like has a
really important like it's this sort of
like Central
this central element this whole thing
revolves around this API because now
it you you put a thing up in front of it
you put an app in front of it and now
non-coders can use the API or you have
API interaction functions and how data
scientists can use it or you need to
expose it to engineering for some reason
and now engineering can use it and it's
just like it's so cool that like that
one thing can control
all these processes
yeah I love seeing how all the like
pieces fit together and it was reminding
me of the
the bike prediction example we share in
our solution site I just put into the
the chat here
but when you like see everything
individually
like tithe and then tied together like
scheduling our markdown documents
feeding them to an API and then a shiny
app you get to see like the the big
picture there yeah so I'd recommend
checking out that example too
um just scrolling through to see any
other questions I might have missed
oh let's see
I don't think so is there a question
Adam that you were expecting we were all
going to ask you that we didn't
um
yeah I guess um
yeah I I I I know I called out like the
apis can feel a little scary so I was
expecting kind of more questions around
that but I do think that it's like
plumber is super well documented if you
are are afraid to ask plumber Super Bowl
documented on
um
on on the website and I'm sure you
showed that link are already Rachel so
um yeah go check it out if you're if
you're sort of curious about how the API
works and um if you just have you don't
have to deploy the API
um to connect
um you can sort of run it locally on
your own little machine if you wanted to
just try it out and it's it's just it's
super fun to play with once you get the
hang of them and it's so easy like you
write everything in our code if you want
to
um and so it's like you you write our
functions and then you just add a couple
little like
um
comments with decorators in them and
then plumber takes care of the rest it's
just
that's a great great topic to cover
because I did just see an awesome tweet
from somebody
um from the community who said
what is the best way to describe apis to
a five-year-old and one that does not
have computer scientists as parents and
so just curious like what was one of the
best resources for you when you were
just getting started with understanding
apis with understanding apis
um
gosh I I forget
where I started reading about them in
the first place but just because it's
like it's this it's this where people
throw around all the time they sometimes
they use it to mean
um
the code you write to interact with like
a lower level library that that's
sometimes called an API uh sometimes
they mean
um you know something that a a request
you make to a computer server
um in order to like
get some information back
um I I think what was just helpful for
me was just thinking about it as yeah
just like here's here's a standard
agreed upon ways for a way for two
computers to talk to one another
so computer a wants some information
from computer B and they have to speak
the same language to understand
what it is I'm asking and like what it
is I'm getting back
um
and the API is just sort of like it's
just that layer in between that allows
the computers to sort of speak the
common language
um that was sort of the light bulb
moment for me it's like oh yeah okay
this is like a it's just a structured
way for computers to share information
if you go to a web page you're
essentially making an API call to a
server like hey I want to like give me
the contents of this page and and the
services okay great here's all the HTML
and then your browsers is here's the
page
um so that's kind of like like yeah that
um thinking about it in terms of just
like going to a website also helped me a
lot
thank you that was really helpful and I
know we are definitely way over here on
time but I think we got to answer all
the the questions so thank you so much
Adam YOLO
I did just want to also mention if you
were watching this and thinking like
I don't actually know what connect is
yet or I'd be curious to talk to someone
from our studio if you'd like to talk
with someone like Tatsu who's on here
today
um I've included this link here
I'm always so amazed by how many teams
are people from teens don't yet know
that they have these tools available
within their organization so always
happy to help connect you with others
across your company to I mean especially
companies with thousands of employees
it's really hard to know who has
everything
um so if you ever are curious feel free
to reach out directly on LinkedIn to me
or you can schedule a call to chat with
our team there
um but really appreciate you all joining
and all the great questions thank you so
much Adam for sharing your experience
too awesome thanks for having me I
enjoyed it thank you